Not long ago, I got in an argument on twitter
about whether the International Space Station
is in space or in the atmosphere…
I mean, it’s called the International Space
Station -- so of course it is!
Right?
Or… maybe… maybe it’s not.
It seems like a simple question, space starts
at 100 kilometers.
That’s the Karman Line.
The Fédération Aéronautique Internationale’s
demarcation of where space begins.
Then, I reached out to NASA and they confirmed
it.
Yes, internationally, the Karman line equals
space!
I was right!
The ISS is in space.
But, my twitter fighter was also right.
See, the Karman line is actually still in
the atmosphere.
In the thermosphere, actually.
See, NASA spokesperson Dan Huot told me from
a physical science’s perspective, [quote]
“there is no hard-definable point where
space begins… the atmosphere just gradually
decreases the higher you get.”
So, where does space start, really?
Let’s do this graphically:
We are at the bottom of Earth’s atmosphere
here.
In the troposphere.
This is where regular clouds appear, where
weather happens… mount everest, everything.
The troposphere contains about 75 to 80 percent
of all the atoms that make up our blanket
of air.
Above that, practically speaking, there are
three more layers of atmosphere.
The stratosphere, mesosphere, and thermosphere.
The stratosphere is where the ozone layer
is, where planes fly, and where we sent that
360 cam on a weather balloon last year (it’s
awesome).
At the top of that layer the pressure is less
than 1 percent of ground level.
You’re above more than 99 percent of the
atmosphere and we’re only at layer TWO -- we’re
still hundreds of miles from the International
Space Station.
The mesosphere is next this is where meteors
burn up -- they’re moving ridiculously fast,
so even though there’s almost no actual
air -- they hit a lot of it in a short time.
But there’s still the thermosphere, where
x-rays and UV are absorbed and where aurora
manifest.
The air is hot, but there’s so little of
it you’d still feel cold.
Molecules of air so rarely meet when they
do, they naturally sort themselves by type!
Even though we’re calling these things atmosphere
-- there’s not much atmo at all.
The thermosphere extends hundreds and hundreds
of miles.
And is why this argument started.
The space shuttle, ISS, and some low-orbit
satellites do fly in the thermosphere!
But they’re in a near vacuum.
There’s almost no air at all… less than
point-0001 percent of the atmosphere exists
there.
And yet, we’re not done.There’s another
layer.The exosphere.
That same NASA spokesperson told me the shuttle
missions started pre-atmospheric entry at
122km (400,000 ft).
That’s not even in the thermosphere -- but
a FIFTH LAYER: THE EXOSPHERE.
THAT’S RIGHT
Even though the thermosphere is a vacuum,
it’s definitely space, the exosphere is
considered an atmospheric layer by NASA and
some scientists.
Basically, because it’s where the sun’s
rays overpower Earth’s gravity and move
particles around.
But it is huge, extending 190,000 km or halfway
to the moon. On top of that, when the Earth
is in between the moon and sun, the solar
wind pushes particles from our atmosphere
onto the lunar surface along a tail -- called
the plasma sheet.
Bits of Earth’s atmosphere can be thrown
so far it is on the moon.
It’s pretty insane.
Okay, to wrap it up.
In nature, things aren’t binary.
Where does the ocean end…?
At the beach?
The beach is a gradient.
The water goes back and forth, there are tides
and weather…
So, where does our atmosphere end?
Not sure.
Where does space start?
The Karman Line.
100 Kilometers.
Why?
Because it had to start somewhere.
This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Whether you need a domain, website, or online
store, make your next move with Squarespace.
Squarespace is used by a wide range of creatives
and people — musicians, designers, artists,
restaurants, and more.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code SEEKER to get 10% off
your first purchase.
Space is part of nature, which means it’s
complicated and doesn’t always fit into
clean little boxes.
We have to tweak it.
For example, do you know what space actually
looks like?
Chances are, you don’t, because space pics
are usually fake.
Find out more with Amy, here!
What have you twitter-fought about lately?
Any good science ideas?
Let me know in the comments, or on twitter
@tracedominguez.
And please take a second and subscribe.